les frontières est enfermé les gens se
sont rabattus cet hiver sur des loisirs
locaux et la motoneige a connu un regain
de popularité
une situation qui pour certains
agriculteurs entraîner des conséquences
irréversibles
[Musique]
de quelques années on
un téléphone des gens de la municipalité
pour nous aviser que on avait un oeil
aux chevaux qui s'étaient retrouvés dans
la cour d'école
donc le matin on les a sortis comme à
l'habitude évidemment fait pour le taux
pour inspecter la clôture à chaque matin
on prend pour acquis que tout est en
place
le scandale c'est ce qui advient d'eux
cachant la clôture ça avec coupet ou au
cateau l'agricultrice préfère rester
anonyme par peur des représailles
c'est que la tension monte entre
agriculteurs et motoneigistes alors
qu'une minorité sorte des sentiers ce
qui peut causer de graves dommages aux
cultures et aux élevages dans cette
ferme
aucun chemin est destiné au passage des
motoneigistes
résultat certains coûts à travers champs
et passez près des bâtiments ce qui
engendre un bruit qui effraie les vols
on a eu des pertes le gardon élevage de
dindes ont connu les emplacements qui
ont causé la perte de entre 50 et 60
oiseaux qui était à maturité locales aux
dons qui était déjà presque créé pour
pour l'abattage certains agriculteurs
retrouve aussi des déchets dans les
champs
canettes de bière couronne motoneige et
autres débris comme l'a constaté jean
claude poisson dans la ferme familiale à
saint philippe de laprairie au sud de
montréal
cette année je n'ai eu trouveront là qui
ont arrivés pratiquement en même temps
sa musique ça c'est probablement une
bâche de poing une balle en particulier
caven kenneth donc trois vaches sur
traitement de l'option des cd ripping
qui est en rémission lors l amant gens
mangent pas romand jean marot on a fait
deux traitements chocs des antibiotiques
on jette le lait c'est certain que c'est
la perte de poids aux yeux creux il
manque d'appétit le diagnostic du
vétérinaire est sans appel c'est encore
étrangers c'est certain que on a des
mains sûres nous machinerie pour
détecter le métal
mais détecter la mignonne on n'est pas
capable si quelqu'un jette une canne au
délit car puis que j'ai pas la chance de
l'air d'avoir elles passent dans la
machine les tops déchiquetés
les animaux morts à cause du bruit ou
des débris laissés aux champs sont des
cas extrêmes de façon beaucoup plus
fréquentes ce sont les dommages aux
cultures que déplorent certains
propriétaires
on peut distinguer deux types de
dommages les dommages sont des dommages
physiques aux places
un seul passage de motoneige suffit pour
un bris physiques irréversibles comme
c'est arrivé dans la nouvelle culture de
camerise de benoît pèlerins dans le
centre du québec
il est moral qui est arrivé dans nos
chères à la traversée 12,1 et
retraverser 12 autres j'estime à peu
près qu une cinquantaine de corps ont
été touchés
le deuxième type de dommages est dû à
des passages répétés qui vont compact et
la neige
il faut comprendre que la neige a des
propriétés isolantes qui protège les
cultures et donc là on va permettre au
gel peut pénétrer dans le sol et
d'endommager les cultures de façon
permanente dans certains cas il ya aussi
le fait que même en hiver les cultures
sous la neige ont une certaine
respiration est donc sous un couvert de
glace
la plante en plus de difficultés à
respirer et puis elle se trouve excusiez
d'une certaine manière les cultures qui
sont les plus susceptibles au passage
des motoneiges chez les atlantes divers
comme la luzerne me coucher vous avez le
blé d'hiver que vous avez aussi le sec
d'automne
[Musique]
le droits cédés par monsieur poisson
passe dans son champ de luzerne
l'aja piémont iron getti femmes ou
d'hommes calculs pour voir comment ça
représente sur ma ferme stanisière et
puis elle le fait avec les damnés de la
financière agricole du québec
c'est assez fiable je pense on perdait
plus de 1000 kilos de foin le sur cette
bande là ça que c'est tout 1000 $ la
annuellement qui est perdu mais c'est
comme si on est d'accord dont on les
fait consciemment quand on laisse passer
mais les producteurs aimeraient que la
notion de propriété privée soit
respectée
si vous habitez en banlieue où on vient
vous avez une piscine dans le sport
vous pouvez pas imaginer que vous allez
arriver chez vous qui va voir quelqu'un
que vous connaissez pas dans votre
piscine ou dans votre sport alors
pourquoi est-ce que moi quand je suis
sur mes terres à tout moment cher je
croise des gens que je connais pas du
tout je crois pas qu'elle ait maintes
années ges sont volontairement mal
intentionnés j'ai plus l'impression
qu'ils se doute pas à quel point leur
comportement a des conséquences
négatives sur les sur certaines cultures
le québec compte 33 mille kilomètres de
sentiers dont la moitié sont sur des
terres privées agricoles pour la plupart
restaurants auberges station essence le
tourisme hivernal repose beaucoup sur
cette activité
ces trois points 2 milliards de la tombe
économique la motoneige au québec
au niveau des membres on est rendu à peu
près 108 110 milles
malheureusement une minorité qui fait
mal paraître la majorité la pratique des
sentiers de plus en plus populaire c'est
peut-être 60 % de la vente des nouvelles
machines cette année je pense que les
manufacturiers on travaille aussi à
faire de sensibilisation le problème
n'est pas nouveau mais il semble être
exacerbée cette année avec
l'augmentation du nombre de
motoneigistes
au point tel que l'union des producteurs
agricoles du québec et la fédération des
clubs de motoneigistes ont pris la
parole ensemble pour demander aux gens
de respecter les sentiers on a toujours
eu une bonne relation les producteurs
agricoles avec les clubs de motoneige
on a plusieurs fois différé actions des
adeptes de motoneige du ps est un
partenaire majeur la motoneige est basée
sur deux points principal le bénévolat
et les droits de passage qui sont cédés
par les propriétaires font aussi la
journée qui vont la majorité ont dit ou
pensé plus chez nous nos réseaux la
sécurité
je me mets pas du tout pour la fermeture
des sentiers de motoneige faut trouver
des solutions pour que c'est la pratique
de cette activité la demeure
[Musique]
en effet la plupart des agriculteurs
interrogés ne compte pas fermer leur
chemin d'une part parce qu'ils craignent
que sans sentier se soit encore pire est
que les motoneiges à ya un peu partout
d'autre part pour l'économie de la
région et le bien de leur communauté
mais aussi par peur des représailles
il ya des menaces aussi coeur qui ont
été faits là certains producteurs qui ce
qu'ils voulaient se plaindre alors tout
son environnement qui passait et on doit
trouver des solutions le si on veut
protéger l'activité de la pratique de la
motoneige
plusieurs idées émergent des
agriculteurs et des motoneigistes pour
enrayer le comportement de cette
minorité
augmenter la surveillance hors sentiers
le montant des amendes ou encore passer
un permis de moto n'est plus l'upm a
écrit au ministre des transports pour
créer un fonds d'un million pour
compenser les dommages dus au passage
des vtt des motoneiges et autres
véhicules hors route ministre du
tourisme et l'agriculture ont eux aussi
été avisés des problèmes
en attendant agriculteurs et
motoneigistes dénonce la situation sur
les réseaux sociaux et certains
producteurs investissent dans des
clôtures pour protéger leurs chiens
l'année prochaine ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'à plus de mettre les pieds de
ceux qui vont rester là on va aussi
mettre une corde avec des rubans
fluorescents pour être sûr qu'elle mange
on voit où est ma plantation
puis on voit aussi faire un titre assez
à une place où ça dérange tout y passe
avec des pancartes pour dire vous pouvez
pas celle qu'on se dit on peut tuer on
en vouloir à une industrie qui
fleurissent en pour le québec parce que
on élit les inventeurs de motoneige
monsieur bardis attaquer c'est un comble
la motoneige puis je pense que les
producteurs le savent très bien la
majorité des roadsters vend des
motoneiges comme moi pour nîmes s'offre
des moments mais il y en as tu t'en
quelques-uns comme dans n'importe quoi
qui font perdre la face du vestiaire